okay perfect so morning Oh Steve knee
everyone so my name is they are and I'm
working as a data scientist and LMC and
the aim of the talk is mainly about
giving you a short overview about what
we do and how we do it basically how we
apply data science in order to improve
our products and to improve the
experience of our customers for all our
users so in our case data science is
mainly about getting new perspective on
the data we try to like do the data in a
way that it can help us with our goal
basically the goal of the whole company
and the goal is to basically help any
people to find a job that they would
enjoy but we can't present all the
people the same job or the same options
since every person's unique being and
every person has different requirements
or needs so this brings me to a smaller
goal that we have which is kind of
personalization we want to every user to
have like a personalized experience yeah
honor so
so we want every person to have fob
sub optional with fit their exact needs
so how can we apply data science in the
order or how can we apply this science
to achieve that well first of all but
who knows what home she does please
raise your hand
some so for those who don't know who but
l MC stands for it's the company that
runs our job portal just such as job
stuff's easy processes at work around
the corner it's a mobile app so well our
main focus is our job portals so where
we exactly create them essentially
create in marketplace where people are
looking for suitable employers and
employers are looking for suitable
employees and yeah so we have hundreds
of thousands user users monthly browsing
our sites and we want to help them to
ease in fastening the goal which is
looking for a new job so we were
thinking about how you use it
first thing that came to our minds was
giving them some kind of recommendation
or advice basically imagine yourself you
looking for a job and like 90% of this
time that you see you on the job portals
are not really relevant for you you want
to see like a small portion of the
market that's really relevant and
similarly the the employers want to spam
you with be relevant offers because
although tell yeah but that would be a
complete nonsense so that is where our
first product came in to so that's a
recommendation systems which creates
basically a win-win situation when the
users don't get relevant stuff and the
employers just don't spam to show you
the basic concepts of of the recommender
system there are key terms that we apply
is that we have a set of candidates
basically iself users and it's not set
up for job offers which are the items
and they interact with each other for
basically the candidates interact with
the items in the sense of either detail
you or purchase over the both candidate
or both users and the items can have
various properties such as name work or
skill for for the users and location
salary title or subtitle for for the
item and based on these theatres there
are two major approaches that are
applied with respect to recommender
systems there are either
content-based approaches or
collaborative filtering approaches the
content based approaches are based on
matching the properties of both items
and users and they match together they
rank highly than the
that you know match the drama group this
approach is however that you need to
have like the approach is
domain-specific so if you have one kind
of domain you cannot easily transfer it
from one to each other
moreover you have to store all the
sensitive data about the unit about the
users so we went the way with a
collaborative filtering in the beginning
which only needs to know the interaction
without basically between the users and
the items so doesn't matter what your
domain is it can be cars rentals I mean
dating sites anything and the system
will be adapted the domain mover its
language independent so it doesn't
matter whether it's in German French I
mean Czech English doesn't matter
because it only needs to know what the
interaction between unique users and
unique items so the key idea is
basically that the system learns the
requirements or the needs of the users
from a huge amount of interactions well
to say it like a simple way is as in the
real life if you're looking for some
kind of recommendation advice you tend
to ask somebody who you know shares the
same opinion or it is something like
perception of the world so yeah what you
say sorry
so the opinions and the yeah the
opinions in the in the sense of the the
recommender systems are represented by
the interactions so they can be in the
interior either explicit as you you know
you're a stuff on eBay with the Stars or
they can be implicit where you detail
you or you add stuff to your car or you
purchase something where you don't
really intentionally interact with the
system because it gets the feedback that
how you behave on this around or on the
side or in this
so when you are when you connect the
users and the items you have a graph
that looks like this where the fiber
which is over there are the candidates
or the users and the sevens ticket
papers on the bottom are the items to
jump offers you can see that the graph
are only linked in the graph there's all
that linkage between the candidates and
the items so let's say we want to
recommend a user or something and we
know that he is interacted with these
three items so then we take a look what
kind of users are behaving or like
behaving in the same manner that the
user has so we have these two users that
they've interacted with similar items
and obviously there's going to be some
other items that he do users having
interacted with well-used over there the
other one and these are most likely
candidates to be most likely items to be
for recommendation and these two users
or the users no general are creating
some kind of like a neighborhood because
they're similar to care and we call the
neighbors because they resemble or they
should share the same space within the
graph so they resemble neighborhoods in
real life as with your neighbors
similarly if we swap the toss around we
can find items that are similar to each
other and they also create a
neighborhood in themselves so if we want
to recommend something we take a look at
the neighborhood and we see that these
three items are most likely to be
earth-like most most relevant for our
user or we just want the task around and
if he's viewing a particular item we can
recommend some other items that are
similar to the one that he is been
leaving and obviously this graph looks
really trivial because it's a poor
example about in general we have like
millions of users and thousands of
interactions which is great because it
makes yeah the upper
resistant to outliers because it
averages the opinions on the other hand
that makes it really hard to maintain
because the computational power and the
memory that it needs well that's the
second part of our work which is then
wireless system running can you try to
investigate somehow to find which kind
of data is most relevant for the for the
up3 algorithm and which data is obsolete
or 11 so we just don't overload the
system with it and I suppose that's the
end of the first part which would become
the system I was thinking about showing
an example but that'll leave it to the
end and I will swap the second part the
work so once we have the system running
we realized that the personalization is
excellent choice but it's kind of
general because if you if you want to
have more direct recommendation you need
at least something to know about the
users and I mean some kind of background
or skill and what's wonderful is that
all this stuff is presented the
curriculums which has outreach which are
however in written form which is so
really hard to understand by the
computer in order to get that mr. Genest
and that the computer I replay the
numbers tables equations but they
perform really badly when it comes to
like easy tasks that are good for people
I mean like you look at mention you need
to understand that there's building or
tree or what's in the image but the
computer doesn't get that no at least
it's the representation so with no fear
of further Guardians it doesn't get the
semantics of the image and similarly
with a bit attacks it only sees the
character representation not the
semantics and that's why language
processing
introduces sort of techniques that will
somehow allow the computer to understand
later and that's where the second part
of all the talk is going to be about
it's going to be the holy pie
singing that and so basically we created
the document parser which can transform
into document into new a set of
structure data that the computer can
that the computer can work with and well
so sorry uh well we have create the
different parts of them well can adapt
to any kind of well to any kind of
document type in any language only
energy to like advanced ability to it to
learn some examples so right now we have
a government person looking at transform
documents and check code language that
are of like somehow like curriculums or
or job offers but we're currently
thinking about or we're planning to
incorporate a language throughout the
year as well
and what is it enhancer it puts an
output so it the inputs are formed of
priorities like curriculums that you can
see on the left and you can see that
like all the curricula to look really
different there's a large variety on the
other inputs and when it takes is
basically any kind of text format I mean
like Microsoft Office formats PDFs text
files anything and transform this like
large party of inputs into smaller
outputs so you get a structured beta
which is beautifully normalized and by
structure that mean that we know that
which part of the text belongs to name
surname address and by uniform I mean
like we always get in the same manner or
the output so it doesn't matter whether
the person lives in the
that well I communicate well I'm coming
to all I have communication skills the
the alcohol will always be like tag
communication skills so there are and
these that it's normalizes which are
like name surname address work
experience so what happens in between
either put that inputs and outputs
that's how document parser works it's
basically it get goes from the biggest
part of the text it takes the entire
document and transform it into plain
text that you can see on the right so we
get rid of all the layouts cause team on
the fun stuff that into there and we
focus only on the time so once that is
transformed and we can detect the
language and document type because we
are interested on the Czech language and
we want only curriculums and and don't
and curriculums and job offers and Czech
language basically so what we don't
what is them is that if you imagine a
news article or you sound like a book
traveling it's mainly gonna come oh you
gonna find words like a beech forest
buzz plane or anything on the other
night if you have jump off or through
them you're more likely do
the words like work experience education
skill and based on this we can divide
what we can differentiate with this kind
of like a different text format or yeah
there's formats and languages so once we
have for the correct document types and
program which document parser takes a
look at the entire text and split it
into sections so we have section for
personal stuff education work experience
and skills then we can take a look at
smaller parts of the text which are we
call sub the sub sections mainly for
education because you're gonna have like
your various schools for your bachelor's
different for your masters what we
obviously went to high school some
people and you know more likely it's
going to be you for the work experience
because people tend to work with in
different companies not really everybody
spends the whole lifetime in one company
so then we take a look at the smaller
parts which are entities and we have
various labels for name surname address
book address email there we go how long
people stay in some job in some school
what kind of feel was that in which
school then it can extract what how long
have you been other in one company under
like one job title and you can
differentiate between where your skills
and their levels language skills and
their levels interest and hobbies and
once all this stuff is labeled it the
entities are resolved so that they
always written it in the same manner
so obviously the most difficult part is
like how to label the data so that's
done by dividing these complex tasks
into smaller ones so once we detect a
section in the text we know that for
example if I have work experience
section
I'm not going to get personal stuff in
there so we can have a set of like
specialized entity vectors for each of
the section so then we can increase the
performance of dark algorithm and once
all the stuff is labeled we can just use
simple new rules to normalize it and
like obviously setting the labels is
like the most difficult part and that's
just that done because so we show
different parts enough examples of how
it should have been done as you saw like
Plato text that's that's basically how
it's done we have another annotation
tool that we use for marking the text
and easy and fast way and we just have
it like obviously have a training and
testings plate so we have a set of
training document that we attend
training on language model and then we
have different set for our evaluation
the model so that once we have why it's
called reliable performance of about 95%
we are we do it basically we increase
the amount of data until we get the
performers that we want and we're going
to increase it up to 10,000 documents
and that's what we use the evaluation
tool for the annotation tool for because
it's so quite painful and honestly it's
not really fun to on a team together and
I wanted to get the point that something
you might example as a crucial thing I
mean imagine your own state's the same
way is you're teaching kit if you show
the kid like all the red cars it will
associate the directly with red color
with the cars similarly if I would show
the kids like only like rectangles
triangles circles I would say all this
is cross like any generic prototype
would be across so that's why we created
like quite a complex or annotation
manually so like each person annotating
the text would do it in the same manner
and once so we have this manual we could
then invite people interested in
annotation to help us with the task so
we have a coin get select
process or he gave the annotation memo
to the people and we gave them few
documents and the people that were most
coherent with the manual were asked
whether they could continue with with
the annotation campaign well even though
we thought the annotation one minor was
really complex so we still had to
provide an online feedback or all I hold
is for the people because they you
wouldn't believe how people are creative
and innovative when it comes to writing
curriculums and I wasn't just because G
we had to keep the on page to work in a
fine and the winner help of tomorrow 30
another year's wearable together today
is set in about three months and that it
took us about nine months or a year
until we had quite a good performance on
the on the detectors so where we had
about 90 percent and the stuff that was
crucial for our future work and well I
suppose that's it for the stuff that we
do if you have any question I would do
be a perfect time to ask now I could
also make a demo example about how the
recommendation works if you're
interested I'll just hold it for me any
question in the audience already so what
is your question so in the beginning you
told us that you've engaged a model in
collaborative learning and that if user
clicks an offer that's how you build the
similarity
you'll see used information about what
they actually applied or exempt it so
that's yep so the question was to
whether we guess the user clicks on the
top portal presents to the friends -
well the base the person clicks on the
top portal and whether we have a
feedback whether the person could accept
it or not so we have two kinds of
interactions one of them is detailed one
person just like clicks on it just read
through and the signaling whether
whether they respond to me the job offer
so we wait we have different set of
weights for the clubs use because that's
a less important stuff for us but we
want you to have more of the responses
yes so that we have hi-hi ready for that
but we don't measure whether the person
get accepted yeah we we measure how like
interesting via the pages for the user
so the more time they spend a day at
least like because the problem is that
people in HR sometimes like right so job
tight like the chip levels are not
really what the what the position is
about so that that happens one like
person one gets into and three sit for
two seconds as oh it's a different
different job so it's just go away
yes so we measured that thanks I'll just
show you the examples
any other question okay so over there
probably sorry
yeah that's we we had a problem with
that and right now we're thinking about
because now we have a like the oh yeah
at least something some information
about the users because so we have the
document part showed so we can use like
a background information Jews at least
set up something oh well you can have
like upload like upload your file click
create a landing page where you search
not by like ferry or you can search by
it's a like a future work we could like
a five upload your CV and then you yeah
whoa we have to look and we have still
haven't time to get actually I was
always said the at the conference last
last week or two weeks ago and basically
the best paper that the one the whole
conference was about like are we really
making much approach with the year with
Neverland sm9 so yeah that that was kind
of funny oh so basically we have a lot
like what how is your plate and if we
send a recommendation and in the session
log in like 5-10 minutes we find out
that the people who responded or at
least detail view something we counted
as as like good Dalek good so it's
called
like a performance basically is China in
the beginning but right now we were
comparing with the previous version
version yeah we were considering like
still that was actually one of the
different paper that was there like but
people should focus more on like giving
like a strong baseline not really uh
like using a good baseline because then
you're like complain incorporate with
previous version but a base like to be
like wait wait there
sorry that's the delete engineer or
there yeah oh sorry one question over
there we we only use data that we have
constant for because that's very
important for us and we don't use like
any external and external libraries like
an extra source of of CDs doesn't answer
your question okay
yeah demo
yes so openly and new browser and so
right now I'm entering the site yep so
so the side doesn't know anything about
me so oh I want to I want just find a
new job because the one that I'm working
on is really perfect and or not
listening so over thing so over here
yeah because the that department with a
co-star that the system doesn't know
anything about me so it will basically
recommend like a most popular stuff but
I hope it works I'll try to find some
more relevant stuff to this come friends
and I want to work with right
yeah it's a lot of money so if anybody's
interested there's so there's still a
movement other stuff but if I click on
the second page I can see that yeah
there's a lot of like other stuff about
parking lot my outputs and what's what's
great about the system is that it
doesn't care like it doesn't know what
the Python is doesn't know what like
Python developer does but it knows like
what I'm searching for and still it like
finds a really good stuff for me even
though it there was like three responses
to to the system and people with that
material might seem like three other
stuff that's relevant to parking even
though it doesn't know anything about it
so are there any questions
oh all the stuff is making person oh
great if you have any other questions so
I'll be wrong just ask Thanks